la rentrée 2015 de l'université paris
saclay c'est la première rentrée où
l'université en tant que tel va
accueillir des étudiants au sein des
établissements qui sont membres de
l'université paris saclay avec trois
faits très marquant d'abord tous les
étudiants auront les cartes d'étudiants
pour logo de l'université paris saclay
qui leur donnera vraiment un nouveau
sentiment d'appartenance
ces cartes porte aussi la marque des
établissements mais nous devons créer
aussi ce sentiment plus collectif au
niveau de paris saclay
c'est aussi la première fois que nous
accueillons des étudiants en master ces
master ont été accrédités au niveau de
l'université paris saclay 49 mentions de
master nous avons procédé pendant tout
l'été à l'identification des étudiants à
travers des candidatures à leur
répartition dans les différentes
mentions et nous attendons environ dix
mille étudiants pour cette rentrée ce
sera la première fois que les master
seront vraiment mutualisée au niveau de
diversité
il y aura aussi des étudiants en
doctorat des écoles doctorales ont été
totalement fusionnée au niveau des 18
établissements environ 1500 qui étudiant
sont sont attendus qui l'a aussi seront
le fer de lance de notre université
dernier point je n'ai pas évoqué c'est
la recherche
cette rentrée sera aussi le moment où la
signature commune de l'université paris
saclay va être lancé tous les articles
entre huit et dix mille suivant comment
on les compte chaque année porteront
dorénavant cette nouvelle marque
université paris saclay qui permettra de
nous rendre plus visible depuis
l'international